just days after a stunning announcement
from Prince Harry and Megan Markell
about stepping away from their royal
duties we've learned she is back in
Canada with her 8 month old son Prince
Harry is still in England reportedly
trying to work things out with the royal
family
MTS ty a visit Buckingham Palace with
more on this story good morning to MTS
it's been a rough couple of days for
Harry and Megan it's a future and he
clear for the two of them today good
morning Gail it certainly has been a
rough few days but we're hearing from
the Queen now she has directed royal
staff to come up with a workable
solution and I'm quoting here to work on
Harry and Megan's plans but that plan is
really polarizing public opinion the
price she for is like a fairy tale film
and it's not big news coming out of the
palace Harry and Megan's stepping back
from royal duties what do you think good
idea no not really no why not he's a
royal prince she's married into that
she's trying to change it Harry and
Megan's plans were publicized with this
new highly produced website which went
live shortly after their bombshell
announcement and while they might be
giving up on some royal duties they're
keeping their royal titles as the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex with a mission to
carve out a progressive new role as
financially independent Royals the
person who holds the purse strings for
their six and a half million dollars a
year in expenses is Prince Charles
according to the couple the future king
foots the bill for ninety five percent
of their costs with the taxpayer paying
the rest a claim some royal aides are
questioning whatever the case over in
the US the couple has rock-solid support
and the words of Hannah Montana I think
it's kind of the best of both worlds I
hope it works out for him because I mean
I think it's a great plan on paper it
really says a lot about their
relationship and like how much strength
is there Julie Monte you or VY countess
hitching Brooke as she's now known is
originally from Illinois and married to
a British aristocrat she says she knows
exactly what Megan is going through
everything started so great
they had this sun-drenched wedding and
look at where we are now a year and a
half later she didn't expect this she
said that I did not expect this at all
and I've tried very
to fit in but I can't just survive I
need to thrive now the British press is
continuing to try to poke holes into how
Harry and Megan will thrive financially
but Tony it's pretty clear the couple
wants to do things their own way yes
thank you very much as soon as the more
the British press plays this up and
criticizes them the more they make the
case for why they want this split in the
first place yes it's so interesting to
see the different reactions in this
country and what the reaction that they
have in the UK you know they're just
there has to be a way to work this out
so that it's a win-win for all sides
involved tough to watch though
you